دعت نقابه الفرنسيه الى مظاهرات اليوم هي
الرابعه عشره من نوعها رفضا لقانون
التقاعد الذي اثار موجه من الاحتجاجات في
البلاد وينتظر ان تشهد كبرى المدن
الفرنسيه مثل باريس
ومرسيليا مظاهرات رافضه للقانون من باريس
معنا الان مراسل الجزيره محمد البقالي ما
الذي يمكن ان يضاف لموارد في هذا الخبر
محمد
الذي يمكن ان يضاف ازدهار هو ان هذه
التظاهر هذا اليوم ربما ستعرف تراجعا على
مستوى الزخم ذلك ان النقابات تتوقع ان
المشاركين في التظاهرات هذا اليوم سيكون
اقل مما سجل في فاتح مايو
وهذا ما يعني بالنسبه لكثيرين الى نهايه
هذه الدوره الاحتجاجيه في انتظار دوره
اخرى وهو ما يعني بشكل من الاشكال ان
الحكومه والرئيس قد تمكن من فرضها الامر
الواقع من خلال رفع سنيه التقاعد من
الثانيه وستين الى الرابعه وستين وصلت
الداخليه تتوقع مشاركه ما بين 400 الى 600
الف شخص في كل انحاء فرنسا من بينهم 60
الى 70 الفا في باريس المسيره ستبدا
الانطلاق في هذه اللحظه والواضح يمكن
بالمقارنه مع تظاهرات فاتح ان الرقم او
عذاب المتظاهرين هي اقل بكثير لكن
خساره النقابات او النقابات لرهانيه
الشارع لا يعني ان الحكومه والرئيس قد حقق
انتصارا كبيرا الا من جهه فرض هذا القانون
بعد ذلك على المستوى السياسي فان هذا يعني
مزيدا من الاحتقان مزيدا من الغضب
والنقبات تتوعد بانها ستواصل الاحتجاج
ربما في الدخول المقبل
والاحتقان الشعبي يزيد ولا يعرف كيف ولا
متى سيصفر عن نفسه وهذا على المستوى
السياسي سيعقدها المهمه بالنسبه للرئيس
وبالنسبه للحكومه خاصه في ظل اجواء تضخم
كبير ادت الى ارتفاع اسعار واحتقان شعبي
كبير على المستوى السياسي الحكومه
المعارضه تراهن ولكن في الحقيقه رهانها
يبدو ضعيفا جدا على مشروع قانون سيتم
تقديمه يوم الخميس في البرلمان الفرنسي
يهدف الى ابطال هذه الماده التي نصت على
رفع سن التق الرابعه وستين هذا لكن هذا
المشروع حظوظه في النجاح ضئيله جدا بل
يتوقع ان ترفضه رئيسه مجلس النواب ان ترفض
مناقشتهم من الاصل وان تتقدم بماده في
الدستور تمنع مناقشه المواد التي من شانها
ان تثقل موازنه الدوله وبالتالي لا احد
تقريبا يراهن على البرلمان في ان يغير
شيئا على هذا المستوى يبقى مساله اخيره
وهي مساله الوضع الامني
محافظه الامن اعلنت بانها ستنشر 11 من
عناصر الامن وانها تتوقع دخول من تسميهم
بالمخاص بالمخربين او المكسرين جماعات
البلاك بلوكس تقول ان الفا منهم قد
يتسربون الى مظاهرات باريس وهذا ما يعني
احتمال وقوع اعمال عنف هذا المسار من
باريس مراسل الجزيره محمد البقالي شكرا
جزيلا لك